many protesting for Palestinian rights
in Israel say they are fast becoming
further marginalized major protests
against the new far-right government and
its plans to change the judicial system
are occupying the minds of many in the
country these demonstrators in Jaffa
argue the tens of thousands protesting
in Tel Aviv against the government are
right to fear the worst and want to save
God democracy
but the few injustices and
discrimination against the Palestinians
are worsening and that's being
overlooked this issue it's the main
cause of conflict and bitterness between
both sides and it's totally against my
personal value and also for my point of
view against the jewishism value there
is a very few
Israeli Jewish citizens as you see who
are supporting our struggle some of them
are anti-zionists the others are liberal
Democrats who really look for
a common life on best of complete
equality
they are calling themselves the camp of
equality they are calling for equal
rights for both the Israelis and the
Palestinians alike and they believe that
all successive governments and Israel
have not addressed the root cause of all
problems which is as they say the
occupation
[Music]
the protesters in Tel Aviv accuse prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu of plotting
with his new partners to dismantle
Democratic checks and balances but for
this Israeli Peace activist there is one
big missing piece in the political
jigsaw we need to acknowledge the deep
and the deep roots of of the problem
which are not only this government but
the whole Zionist regime we're talking
about Decades of indoctrination and of
concealing the historical facts of what
has been going on here from 48 and even
before
for these protesters discrimination
against the Palestinians is growing and
they say that will get worse in Israel
and they occupied territories as long as
its people are treated differently Ahmed
al-jazeera Jaffa